prime minister justin trudeau held a
teleconference today with many of the
country's provincial and territorial
premiers it's their first meeting since
mid-december and since the omicron
variant pushed case counts and
hospitalizations to record highs our
chief political correspondent david
aiken has been tracking the meeting for
us today so david what was on the agenda
well the first thing the prime minister
justin trudeau wanted to do was to go
around the table see how all the
premiers are coping with omicron that's
top of mind at provincial capitals but
the prime minister also wanted to get a
sense of where future requests for
federal assistance might come from right
now for example we've got the canadian
army in quebec helping out with the
vaccine program there and the pm wanted
to find out what sort of in the pipeline
might be in the pipeline down the road
and that came with a warning that there
are only so many canadian red cross
workers only so many medic or army
personnel and have to be smart with that
resource the prime minister also talked
about support for small business of
course there's a slimmed down version of
that canadian wage subsidy program and
the prime minister wanted to find out
from premiers how that was going and
whether or not they need to make any
adjustments
and there's also been a lot of
speculation david about whether ottawa
might push to make vaccines mandatory
particularly after the health minister
johnny duklow raised that very issue
last week so was that on the table at
all today
no not really and you know what that
comment from duklow was really the
health minister shooting from the hip
that's what one source in a premier's
office told me there's really no serious
federal proposal to do that and in fact
as soon as duclos said what he said two
premiers alberta's jason kennedy and
saskatchewan scott moe came out right
away and said no way no how they're dead
set against any broad-based mandatory
vaccination program
right so some premiers clearly don't
want vaccine mandates so what do they
want what were the provinces and
territories asking for today david
well they want more money for health
care jeff and you know this is something
they've asked about every time they meet
with the pm going back 18 months with
not much success but one other thing two
premiers kenny and ontario's doug ford
also pressed the pm on anti-viral pills
now these are pills that people take as
soon as you are feel symptoms from covid
studies show they can prevent serious
illness they're approved for use in some
countries they're not approved yet for
use in canada and both kenny and ford
think these anti-viral pills
particularly the one from pfizer could
be key tools to keep people out of
hospitals and so they were asking health
canada quickly please approve these
pills jeff
david aiken in ottawa thanks david